well during an interview with the  president a he blasted FBI agent struck  in page as well as former CIA director  John Brennan accused them of acting out  of malice here's part of that I think  brent is a very bad guy and if you look  at it a lot of things happened under his  watch I think he's a very bad person I  also think that when you watch Peter  Strock and Lisa page when you watch all  of the things that have happened and  Combe happened Comey take a look at that  and McCabe who's got some pretty big  problems I assume you look at the  deception the lies these are people that  in my opinion are truly they're bad  people and they're being exposed for  what they are it's part of a much longer  interview the entire extended version  airs tomorrow 8:00 p.m. we hope you'll  watch